Okay, so let's continue from last time
where we implemented linear regression
in neural network from scratch. So back
then we didn't use any of the tools that
uh we introduced using back propagation
and the autograd in uh pytorch. So here
we are slowly bringing them into the
implementation. Okay. So we import
mattplot liap and torch
and then uh we also import the typing
and the reason is this type hints
basically help documentation
and what our functions are expecting and
returning and also makes the code more
maintainable. We generated a synthetic
data and here last time if you remember
we had some issues with the tensor
shapes here we basically make sure that
we are not getting that anymore before
going into the details of the code I
want uh to get your attention for this
figure from the book figure 5.3.1
this is um just a schematic of a
computation graph graph and uh as you
see here we have the values of x w all
in square. So these are the items that
can take value and we have some
operations over them. So if you remember
in back propagation we start from
[clears throat] last loss value and then
propagate that backward and uh the last
points of this backward propagations are
those values that we start from and we
uh apply some operations. So for example
here the weights these two weights and x
which is the input uh data and the rest
will be based on these values or the
parameters of the neural network and
input [clears throat] data the leaf
tensors. So leaf tensors
and non-leaf tensors are important
concepts that we have to consider during
our implementations. Again leaf tensor
are instantiated directly. They are not
the [clears throat] result of an
operation uh over some other leaf tensor
and we keep the value of their
gradients.
So the function backward the method
backward that you will see that
basically apply the back propagation
will store the grad values for these
tensors leaf tensors for the other
non-leaf tensors the grad will be
removed or basically the entire
computation graph will be removed for
saving memory essentially and uh the
gradient for those values are not uh
stored. So for example when we initiate
the weights and biases for example here
those are the leaf values but if we
apply some other operations on them and
maybe introduce new values the new value
will be a non-leaf tensor. So after
calling backward
uh you can basically print the grad
attribute of leaf tensors but for
non-leaf tensors there will be no grad
attribute. If we want to update the the
values of the parameters following the
computation of the gradients for example
we are trying to update the weights. So
previous weight minus the learning rate
by the the gradient of the of the leaf.
But notice that this is a leaf note and
we are doing some operations on that
that makes it a non-leaf note. And then
after that all of the issues that we
discussed above. The right way to do it
is basically we have to tell PyTorch
that we want this to be kept as a leaf
node. So this is a way for PyTorch to
keep the parameters out uh updates
outside of the autograd [clears throat]
uh because otherwise memory usage will
explode gradients of gradients and then
runtime errors when we [clears throat]
reuse this modified parameters and uh
some other problems. Okay. So let's uh
quickly summarize this methods.
The torsional grat is very common. We
disable the autograd and then we can
update the parameters. Maybe we want to
do inference.
Uh the tensor data. This is a direct
access to the underlying data. The
detach is a way of creating new tensors
without the grat history.
And then basically it will work like a
leaf node. So for example if we want to
do some in place operation that is not
introduced new variables for example uh
value x and we do some operation over it
multiply by two we introduce y. Now if I
add something to x [clears throat]
now this is an in place operation. For
example, if we compute the loss minus
the y sum and do the loss backward. So
it basically
tells that uh now a leaf variable that
requires grat is being used in an in
place operation. We don't want that. And
here to avoid that we have to produce a
new x and then we continue doing this.
We are okay.
Okay. So um it's it's good to discuss
another behavior of auto define in
PyTorch. So for example, if we do the
backward once and then do it again,
right? Do another backward. Uh this
basically adds up the gradient for the
weights. Okay, which uh this will give
me wra
that I want. But here after doing this
step we will get rad of one plus rad of
two and that means that basically
gradients accumulate. So to avoid that
we have to zero the uh the gradient. So
with self
grad uh
so whenever if we haven't uh zero
the grad
in that case the self.w.grat
Grat is not none. We have to make sure
to zero it and this is how we are doing
it. We check first and then we zero and
then after that we can do a fresh
backward. Okay. [clears throat]
In PyTorch um we have the optimizers
that are basically doing this operation
for us updating the W's and doing this
gradient descent. So for example a
stocastic gradient descent is an
optimizer that we use like this here we
compute the new gradients and then here
we update the parameters. So in each
forward pass this will compute a a
computation graph and here if we do the
forward pass again this will make the
second graph independently. Then if we
somehow have we have a let's say we have
a loss function here and uh we compute
the loss here and if I do a backward
here this will compute the backward pass
for the first computation graph
and it will free graph one. So but graph
two is still there. So that's how uh we
know PyTorch is handling this memory uh
or managing it. And um if we are not
careful let's say we have a loop over
different batches right uh in our
whatever data loader we have and uh here
[gasps]
um so we do a forward pass we get the uh
inferred Y bread with the current model
parameters and then we compute the loss
and let's say we want to store this loss
Right this loss if I don't do this say
we are doing this instead then if I do
loss backward each time we append the
computation graph in memory and then we
do the the backward. So this is not uh a
good practice because of the the memory
leak that is happening here. So let's
just instead of the uh computing
computation graph let's just store the
scalar value of loss which is after all
our purpose here. Okay let's um write a
summary of this uh common things
[clears throat] that uh can happen and
how to handle them when dealing with
non-leaf parameters. we get this error
for in place operation like we did. The
issue with
um computation graph uh storing a
gradient uh [clears throat] that is not
converging and one reason can be we are
not zeroing the gradient and there's a
accumulation of it. Uh we will go over
the example of linear regression. We
will show that there are some best
practices that we can follow to minimize
this type of errors.
Okay. So let's uh go back to that class
of linear regression that we uh were
working on and um you can write um um
and um then let's write the init value.
Then let's write the
init method. And here recall that's uh
the learning rate is a float. And let's
just put a [clears throat]
like a default value for that. Okay. So,
uh let's introduce the weights here.
Going to just [clears throat] go with a
default for now. And you see that uh we
started with from random. And notice
that here we have a require grad as
true. And if you remember I said this is
a leaf value
leaf tensor and [laughter] accepts a
gradient. Uh for example input data is
also leaf tensors but they they don't
have uh gradient and they are constants
but weights and biases are not constants
and we want to tell pytorch that. Okay.
So let's just reduce this value even
more. If you remember we discussed this
in parameter initialization
and here we have the biases and
let's just stick with my own
shorter
what else we have the input
uh size as the input size and then it's
good to have some print statement to
just um show the sizes
Okay, so with that let's write the first
um function. Um so we have the forward
method and the forward method here takes
X returns a tensor which is simply the
operation in this one layer neural
network. Okay, next let's compute the
loss and and then let's do the
back our own back one. So here basically
we want to um simulate or do what uh tap
pytor is doing behind the scenes. So
here we have x y. Okay. So let's just do
like what we did last time. We have uh
the gradient of w and gradient of
[gasps]
uh biases. You see that we already
have a nice suggestion.
Um we had a two over n here
[clears throat] if you didn't remember
but um well let's put it here. Uh but we
have to keep a value of n if
[clears throat] we want to do it and
it's not really necessary. So let's just
avoid it to make our life easier. So now
you see that we have u uh autograd like
uh storing of the gradients but we
discussed that it's always a good
practice to check if the uh gradient is
uh already zero or not. If it's not zero
we have to zero it. So let's do it.
Okay. And now we make sure that the
gradients are zero. And then we can uh
store them. And then after that uh let's
go for our gradient step. So let's see
what we have x and y. And then we return
a step. Okay. So notice that here um we
have the forward and that uh computes a
yhat and then we compute the loss here
and then we do the manual backward. Uh
one thing that I don't like is we uh
compute it we do the forward pass twice.
So why we should do it? Let's avoid
that. is set uh I had here
and um y had here update the parameters.
Okay, so let's do it. So this is that
[clears throat]
and then we return the last item. Um so
here the last item is a float
and so maybe I should say that here. I
mean doesn't hurt to be more accurate.
Okay. So, u get this basically give us
the step of the gradient descent. Okay.
So, with that uh let's do some debugging
and let's see where are uh the holes in
our code. So, first I'm going to make
some uh data and then we are running the
model. Okay. So, let's see what we have.
We have the regression model. This is
our first step. uh we do want gradient
descent. Okay. So let's see. Okay.
So notice that the problem is here where
we are
um storing the gradient of the bias that
we computed
and uh the assignment that has an issue
is we are assigning a scalar to a
tensor.
Okay. So that's not what we want to do.
So let's fix it here.
This is a scalar because of how we are
computing it. And uh the good thing is
we can just tell uh PyTorch to reshape
that to whatever it really wants to. So
let's just reshape
it uh to
uh whatever is the shape of the B rat,
right? So let's just write
uh grat
and shape. Uh actually you know what we
don't want the grat because just need
the shape of B. Okay, so let's try
again.
Okay, we got an error an warning and the
warning is [clears throat] uh we are
accessing a lift tensor make we are
making it a non-lift again that's uh
dangerous
um maybe one obvious thing here is we
are
uh we discussed this right so we don't
want to
update the leaf tensor if the self do
that w.grad
course or course same for B is uh
[groaning]
in the gradient mode. So we have to tell
PyTorch that. Okay. So with torch no
grad
we want to do this updates.
Okay. So that's that.
Ah we have another one. So what's going
on here? There is a leaf tensor
that we are touching it.
So we are basically doing some operation
on a leaf tensor. Let's find that leaf
tensor that we are touching it. So we
fix this
uh this is okay.
These are
uh some constant.
This is leaf tensor that we introduce.
And this is a leaf tensor that we
introduce. And we do an operation on it.
Oh, we don't want to do that. So let's
remove this. Let's try again. And we are
good. Let's do another step gradient
descent and see if things are not
accumulating.
Uh
I see that we have some
let's see if
last two
can remove this. No we are okay. There
is no error.
We are good. So so far so good. Let's
continue. Okay. So now that we have the
the manual version [clears throat] in
place, let's uh implement
a pure autograd version of this.
So we have a linear uh regression
and we [snorts] are going to use the
version of it and I want to inherit
all what torch nn has to offer. Okay.
So, usually what we do here just to uh
use a [clears throat] um um
like a conventional import we import to
n
uh as nn just to
be
more in line with uh the practice. So,
we don't need that. Okay. So with that
we have the NN module
inside that and notice that uh Google
Collab already did the super indeed for
me. If for example we don't have uh this
call and we want to do for example a
self
linear
um layer like here
uh if I don't have that yet for example
if I have this commented
and if I run this this will fail
basically you can think of But like we
want to build a house on a foundation
and we have to have the foundation first
and super is basically making a
foundation and then we are building up
over it using the methods within it. For
now let's um move this uh
[clears throat] for later and make keep
it simple for now. I mean even we can
move the learning rate
uh outside of this and the main reason
is uh we want to give this away to the
optimizer
not uh keeping it here [gasps] and we
want to keep the architecture as
independent as possible from those
decisions.
So with that I'm going to even simplify
and um one thing else maybe is to uh if
we want to compare this with uh the
the manual version that we wrote up u we
let's initialize
it to be similar to the manual version.
So with torch
uh no grad I want to initialize it. So
we want to initialize it as a Gaussian.
Uh so let's go back see how we
initialize this.
Okay. So notice that we
um we remove the that scaling and this
may be a bit large for the starter and
uh like we discuss uh we
don't want to do an operation on this uh
after
we introduce it as a leaf node. So one
way to reduce this is to first just
introduce this as a concept constant and
um as a constant and then after that we
will set the gradient on for it. So
let's
uh do a check again if everything looks
okay here.
Yep. So
>> [groaning]
>> uh let's continue here. Um let's uh add
some print statements to [clears throat]
basically check the initialization
and uh [clears throat] okay.
Okay. So we initialized the the class
and we added a linear layer. Now we want
to specify how we are doing the forward
right. So here let's see what we have as
suggestion. Uh we take tensor we return
tensor [gasps] uh basically by doing a
forward pass. Nice. Good. So what else
we want? That's it really. But let's uh
extract the parameters too uh this way.
So notice that we don't want step
because we
uh delegate all of that to the optimizer
later. So here I just want to write a
method to get the parameters and we want
to make it easily readable. So let's
just do some operation on them. So with
torch no grat we want to return
the
weights.
Uh
yep I want weight data flatten to list
and by self
linear bias item.
Okay
sounds like a plan. [gasps]
Okay. So with that we can start
training.
So we had the training of the manual
version very similar from before. Going
to just maybe I can add it right after
this to be closer.
So here we are training the manual where
we have a verbose. We have several
epochs.
Uh like I said, we shuffle the data and
then we initialize the last and the
number of batches
and then we make the batches of X and Y.
We do a step descent on this batch and
then we add the loss for each apoch
and we control the number of
apoch to compute the average loss so far
in the epoch. Then we print this out.
Then at the end we have the apoch
losses. So basically the average loss of
each epoch. Okay. and for the auto
version. So instead of doing this um
data loading ourself, let's use the
utilities in PyTorch.
So the first one is we want to
use the the data loaders uh in PyTorch.
So we have the tensor data set and data
loader
which basically data loader handles the
batching, shuffling
and uh also parallel data loading which
is very handy for large data sets. What
does the tensor data set do? help uh it
helps us to wrap tensors into a data set
for the data loader.
So without tensor data set we have to
manually create our own custom data set
class uh that keeps the x train and y
train synchronized
and that's a lot of work for something
that common and uh we pytorch as a way
to simplify our life. Uh what else we
want? uh we already import the optin
here so we need that too. Like I said
this provides the optimization
algorithms like stochastic gradient
descent or Adam or other advanced
algorithms.
Okay. So let's use them.
So here I'm going to write a train
uh method for our
nice mutated
uh model
which is a
and we can take the rest. So within this
function we will have the optimizers.
Okay. So we can take in the uh the
learning rates here. Okay. So with that
let's write the function. So when we
take in x and y we can make the data set
using our uh tensor data set. Then we
have the data loader that takes in this
tensord data set and the batch
uh batches that we the batch sizes that
we determined in the try not to grab
function.
And [snorts]
uh this way we can prepare for the
optimizer. Of course we need a criterion
here and um let's uh oh we have the
criterion in an MSE loss and that's what
we want.
So notice that uh in the suggestion we
had the criterion after the optimizer
which is okay because we are going to
use it within the training loop and we
haven't yet written the loop. So it can
be before or after. Uh okay. So with
that let's write the training loop
starting with the AP classes that we
want to [snorts]
suffer empty and for a in the range of
epox
and we have the total loss and number of
batches. And then now we can use the
data loader.
And for
um badge
um let's keep it similar to what we had
>> [clears throat]
>> uh in the
um manual version and then in in
numerate
and we are using data loader and uh by
default it uh put the zero grad for us
which is nice. Like I said, this can be
a common problem
and commenting out this we'll see uh we
will see the the gradient accumulation.
[clears throat]
Okay. So with that uh we have the
forward here and doing this forward the
autograd will track the operation for
us. Then we have the last computation
the backward
and then the update of the parameters
using the optimizer optimizer.
So let's
update the total loss [sighs]
um the number of batches and then we
have the average loss and epo losses
and then after that we can return
the the epo classes. Uh we can add some
variables
um for debugging
will be for the training loop. Let's put
a bus here. Okay. So, we'll put one here
and
Okay. So, let's write a main function.
And in this main function, we make the
the synthetic data. Let's uh let's do it
like last time where we had a true
weight and [clears throat]
um
uh true B. Let's compare the two model.
Okay, so we have the models
loss of average loss of each epoch and
then do the same for the uh autograd.
So
it's no grad.
Uh what we have? We take in the
um [clears throat and snorts] both the
the
weights flatten that and also the
biases.
Let's see. We get this and then we have
we have this nice method that does it
for our auto model. It's also in the
final [clears throat] loss. Okay. So
let's run this and train autograd and
train manual. Oh, I didn't run this
apparently. So let's try again.
Okay, so the manual is trained. Okay.
Oh, there is an error here. U we don't
have a forward. That's impossible. Let's
go back to
Oh, okay. We never close this here.
Okay, let's um good. Let's go back
and run this. Oh, another error. So, we
our linear regression alpha class
doesn't have a get parameters. I'm
pretty sure I wrote that. So,
[sighs and gasps]
there might be some naming issues. Get
parami
errors of course.
Okay, so let's run again. There will be
always errors. So,
okay. So, another one. [sighs]
Let's just look for any of these
instances. Where is that? You see that
he should be very patient even with me.
We have the final losses and um
weights and biases. So, here was two
that they are all the same. We can also
plot the values of this uh epoch losses.
So let me write a plot.
Okay. So we will add a plot function
here. We already have that and just need
to align it and let's try again.
So notice that the autocrat
um
minimizes the loss faster. And that's
because of the better SGD implementation
than what we did. Uh, of course the
initialization
uh even here it's not exactly the same
but uh we didn't let autograd
go smart on the initialization.
The final result of W1 W2 and bias is
almost the same and we are happy with
that. So,
uh that's